the Hulk may be one of Marvel's most
famous heroes but after the release of
The Incredible Hulk Bruce Banner was
sidelined until the Avengers rolled out
around four years later and even then
the Hulk's role in the MCU has largely
been a supporting one so why did we
never get to see the Incredible Hulk -
when the MCU began their core actors
were in place Chris Evans is Captain
America Chris Hemsworth playing Thor and
of course Robert Downey jr. nailing the
role of Iron Man well three out of four
isn't bad because we all know what
happened with Bruce Banner so why did
Edward Norton fail to make the cut for
Earth's Mightiest Heroes while most of
the actors playing Avengers have had a
long and prosperous relationship with
Marvel Studios Norton seems to have
gotten off on the wrong foot from day
one in fact he doesn't appear to have
even been the first choice for the role
in an interview with The Huffington Post
director Louis Leterrier let it slip
that while he appreciated what Norton
brought to the table his first pick had
actually been Mark Ruffalo I'm to fill
you on top of his runner-up status
numerous rumors have arisen over the
years suggesting that Norton may have
been difficult to work with on the set
that he was very vocal at times when he
disagreed with something and that he was
overly involved in tampering with the
script while none of these are
particularly rare qualities and
Hollywood stars they're not likely to
stack the deck in your favor either it
didn't take long after the film came out
for the first hints of discord to begin
surfacing two years after the incredible
Hulk's release Marvel boss Kevin Feige
made the announcement that Norton would
not be brought back to portray the title
role of Bruce Banner in the Avengers at
the time Feige insisted that the
decision wasn't a monetary one his
statement read our decision is
definitely not based on monetary factors
but instead rooted in the need for an
actor who embodies the creativity and
collaborative spirits of our other
talented cast members Feige statement
made it clear that something had been
going on behind closed doors something
more than a few friendly disagreements
over the script
luckily the Hulk was still set to appear
in the first Avengers movie and would
continue to make appearances in other
characters future films but the removal
of Norton from the role shed a little
light on why Ironman played by the
immensely popular Robert Downey jr.
became the center
burgeoning franchise while the Hulk
languished on the sidelines Norton's
agent was quick to respond to Feige
statement and his rebuttal he said this
offensive statement from Kevin Feige at
Marvel is a purposefully misleading
inappropriate attempt to paint our
clients in a negative light the actor
himself took to social media not to
attack Marvel but rather to express his
disappointment at the way things had
turned out he wrote I sincerely hoped it
could happen and be great for everyone
but it hasn't turned out as we all poked
I know this is disappointing to many
people and that makes me sad but I am
very sincerely grateful to Marvel for
extending the offer and even more for
giving me the chance to be a part of the
Hulk's long and excellent history these
responses from Norton and his agent
seemed to indicate that no matter how
bad things might have been behind the
scenes Norton had continued to hope that
he would reprise his role unfortunately
by Gea's decision put an end to those
hopes as the dust settled Norton
eventually traded his regretful tune for
one of indifference explaining a few
years later that he had lost interest in
the role and instead wanted to act in
other movies and genres while it's been
rumored for years that Norton isn't the
easiest person to work with that doesn't
mean the blame for his removal deserves
to fall squarely on his hulked out
shoulders both Marvel Studios and Disney
have developed a track record over the
years for dismissing various personnel
who haven't fallen in line with their
vision for example Thor the dark worlds
first director patty Jenkins said she
didn't think she could make a great film
out of their script rather than allowing
her to adjust the story the studio
parted ways with the director who went
on to head up Wonder Woman while Marvel
ended up with a subpar sequel to their
Thor franchise Terrence Howard also
infamously lost the role of James Rhodey
Rhodes to Don Cheadle after iron man and
of course there's guardians of the
galaxy franchise mastermind James Gunn
who is fired in 2018 after Internet
users dug up some of his old and quite
offensive tweets while Disney may have
ultimately reinstated gun to his
previous position the whole Norton
debacle wasn't the only
behind-the-scenes misstep Marvel Studios
hasn't Dewart although the actual
details of the behind the scenes breakup
may never be cleared up
one thing was crystal clear as the door
swung shot on Norton
the Hulk's MCU storyline wasn't going
anywhere fast rights are a tricky
business in Hollywood in the case of a
standalone Hulk sequel though there are
even more nuanced than usual while Sony
may own the rights to spider-man
for example the rights to Hulk are more
or less split between Marvel and
Universal but unlike the innovative time
sharing agreement between Sony and
Marvel for Spidey
the Hulk situation has been complicated
by the less than stellar relationship
between the two studios holding the
strings according to forbes Marvel
regained the rights to the Hulk
character in 2005 when Universal
neglected to purchase a sequel to
angley's 2003 movie Hulk but while that
meant Marvel was given the chance to
integrate Hulk into their Cinematic
Universe Universal retained one critical
piece of the puzzle the rights of first
refusal over the distribution of any
solo Hulk film in other words while
Marvel can use the Hulk character if
they decide to make Hulk movie Universal
gets first dibs on distributing the
feature of course Marvel has used other
studios to distribute their movies
before and the lack of distribution
rights alone isn't enough of a reason to
put the kibosh on a sequel but
considering all the other issues the
Incredible Hulk faced during production
and after its release and can't have
helped things much either it's easy to
look at the quarter of a billion that
the Incredible Hulk made in theaters and
dismiss money as a motivation in
Marvel's hesitation to produce a sequel
but the numbers are actually a bit of an
issue even though the movie was released
before the days when Marvel was pumping
out billion dollar projects a couple of
times a year the movie still
underperformed at the box office during
its run norton's Hulk brought in 263
million four hundred and twenty seven
thousand five hundred and fifty one
dollars which is a respectable sum to
say the least but take Iron Man for
comparison that movie which was released
just a few months prior to the
Incredible Hulk and which costs 10
million dollars less to make brought in
twice as much in global ticket sales and
while the Incredible Hulk may not have
been a complete flop it's less than
stellar box-office performance and
middling critical reception likely
suggested to Marvel that the Hulk alone
just isn't compelling in
to draw a big crowd having the Hulk show
up for a handful of epic fight scenes is
exactly the kind of integration that
makes its presence in Marvel's more
recent films worthwhile but the truth is
it costs a lot to produce a whole film
centered on a completely CGI character
and that goes doubly when any scene
therein is going to have to include a
kitchen sinks worth of flying cars
crumbling buildings and all kinds of
mayhem while a huge investment in
special-effects is part and parcel of
bigger crossover releases like The
Avengers movies an entire film of that
nature focused on a single character is
a daunting task to expect the studio to
take on and when you take into
consideration the disappointing box
office reception of the Incredible Hulk
it becomes that much easier to believe
that the Marvel and studio execs
involved in the decision would hesitate
before signing off on such an expensive
project
although the snowball effect of subpar
ticket sales uninspired reviews
production costs behind the scenes drama
and distribution rights would have
already been more than enough to put the
final nail in the coffin at any Hulk
sequel that's not the end of the story
in many ways the true Achilles heel of
the Hulk's one and only MCU outing was
that it simply failed to fit the tone of
the wider MCU whether it was the solemn
introspection that Norton tried to bring
to the role or the inherent difficulties
in exploring the Hulk's mindless
destruction as the centrepiece of a
story The Incredible Hulk ended up
struggling to hit the effortlessly
entertaining tone of most of the
following MCU films taking place in
phase 1 of the MCU Polk's film was set
against characters like the selfishly
sarcastic Tony Stark the lovably loyal
Steve Rogers and the hilariously hunky
Thor all of whom were busy setting the
stage for the first Avengers movie in
comparison Hulk's more serious overtones
stood out like a big green sore thumb
and made the film dark enough to dampen
the enthusiasm of even the most ardent
Marvel fan as if the sobering tone of
the film wasn't enough there's also the
fact that the story started by dropping
the audience into a random spot in
Banner and the Hulk story arc and then
proceeded to take it absolutely nowhere
after skipping over the famous gamma
radiation exposure incident the film
proceeded to meander awkwardly through
banners harrowing Leone her
adventures he finally flashed a little
superhero muscle when he subdued
abomination in the streets of Harlem but
when the film ended shortly after things
once again took a step backward banners
take away from the experience was simply
that he had found a way to come to terms
with the other guy and while this
appeared to be a positive step forward
for the character the fact that it was
quickly retcon when Ruffalo's distressed
banner was brought back on the scene and
the avengers made the whole point of the
film pretty much pointless in july 2017
Mark Ruffalo predicted that quote a
standalone Hulk movie will never happen
and while that may have seemed like the
end of the story you could argue that a
secret Incredible Hulk follow up already
exists
[Applause]
around the same time that Ruffalo dashed
fans hopes have ever seen another solo
Hulk film the actor also revealed in
another interview that he sat down with
Kevin Feige and the two had brainstormed
what a standalone film for the Hulk
would look like once they had a good
idea to work from they decided to
implement it into the wider MCU by
divvying up the story across three
separate movies cleverly none of these
would be released as a standalone film
thus sidestepping the rights issue with
Universal instead the Hulk storyline
would be woven through thor ragnarok
Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame during which his sequel
storyline could finally be told one
piece at a time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]